l'annoncé a été faite en milieu de
journée par le fonds russe
d'investissements directs chargé de la
commercialisation du vaccin à l'étranger
est confirmée dans la foulée par l'
agence européenne du médicament
le sporting est donc désormais en phase
d'examen en vue de sa validation pour le
marché européen
concrètement d'ici deux à quatre mois si
tout va bien sportives et sera approuvé
pourra donc être proposé à la population
de l'union européenne nous nous
félicitons du lancement de la procédure
d'examen séquentielle du dossier
d'enregistrement du vaccin scouts nick v
par l' agence européenne du médicament
nous avons fourni à l'agencé européenne
du médicament
toutes les données nécessaires sur le
vaccin qui a déjà été approuvée par plus
de 40 pays dans le monde
le spoutnik v peut apporter une
contribution essentielle pour sauver des
millions de vies à travers l'europe et
nous attendons avec intérêt l'examen des
données par le comité des médicaments à
usage humain
le partenariat sur le vaccin doit être
dessus de la politique et la
collaboration avec l'agencé européenne
du médicament est un excellent exemple
qui confirme que seule la conjugaison
des efforts peut vaincre la pandémie
l'approbation de l'agencé européenne du
médicament permettra de fournir le
vaccin spoutnik vais à 50 millions
d'habitants de l'union européenne à
partir du mois de juin 2021
de son côté moscou est prêt à fournir
des doses à partir du mois de juin
dès lors que tous les citoyens russes
qui souhaitent se faire vacciner aurait
eu l'occasion de le faire à l'heure
actuelle 2 millions de russes ont reçu
les deux doses de vaccin et 2 millions
de plus la première est comparé aux
autres vaccins le spoutnik v n'a rien à
leur envier à entendre vladimir poutine
nous avons de quoi être fier notamment
du fait que notre vaccin nous vaccins
sont les plus sûrs et efficaces dont le
monde entier
j'ai déjà cité les données que vous
médecin connaissez sans doute bien
astrazeneca est une très bonne société
qui produit un très bon vaccin dont le
niveau de protection et de 61%
le nôtre est de 91 6% en suisse si je ne
me trompe pas on vaccine actuellement la
population avec le vaccin
kaiser seize personnes sont mortes un
certain nombre de pays européens ont
suspendu la vaccination avec le vaccin
files york
car il ya eu des décès en russie
dieu merci nous n'avons eu aucun effet
secondaire grave qu'un jour le deuxième
jour suivant l'administration du vaccin
10% peuvent avoir une température élevée
mais le niveau de protection et le
niveau de sécurité sont élevés nous
avons élaboré le deuxième et le
troisième vaccin ainsi que des
médicaments qui sont très bons de classe
internationale il faut dire que depuis
la publication dans la revue
scientifique de 27 d'une étude qui
prêtent aux vaccins russes près de 92 %
d'efficacité l'intérêt de nombreux pays
s'est renforcé en cas de validation dans
les prochaines semaines spoutnik v
deviendrait alors le 4e vaccin à être
autorisée au sein de l'union européenne